monsieur le ministre la parole et à
madame claude greff merci monsieur le
président ma question s'adresse au
premier ministre monsieur le premier
ministre
notre système de santé rencontrent
aujourd'hui des difficultés importantes
chacun d'entre nous veut sa pérennité
mais je constate que nous n'avons pas
les mêmes choix et surtout l'annoncé de
la fermeture de 16 mille lits est
particulièrement brutale après vous êtes
mis à dos la quasi-totalité des
professionnels de santé libéraux et les
cliniques
car il faut bien l'avouer vous voulez
détruire notre système médical libéral
en france c'est maintenant dans le
secteur hospitalier public que le ton
monte les républicains croient en la
complémentarité entre l'hôpital public
et la médecine libérale et pour faire
aboutir cette réforme sur l'hôpital la
ministre de la santé utilisent les non
dits et sa pédagogie est aux abonnés
absents
la communauté hospitalière n'est pas
déconnectée des réalités elle sait très
bien que les capacités d'accueil doivent
évoluer mais elle a besoin de vérité et
d'un vrai projet ne vous cachez pas
derrière les fermetures de lits pour ne
pas dire que vous voulez réduire les
effectifs pour réduire les déficits
et pourtant madame touraine a bien dit
devant la représentation nationale au
mois de mars et décembre que ce plan je
cite d'économie n'avait pas pour but de
baisser les effectifs et qu'il n'y a
aucune liste d'établissements ou de
services à restructurer et bien on en
est loin
vous voulez transformer certains centres
d'urgence en centres de consultations
sans rendez-vous vous porter un coup
supplémentaire à la médecine libérale
qui remplit déjà cette mission et les
élus dans ce cas n'ont même pas été
consultés ou sera l'intérêt des patients
et des professionnels de santé
votre plan de réduction des dépenses
s'appuie sur quels critères objectifs
face aux grands silences de madame
touraine sur ses intentions
monsieur le premier ministre pouvez vous
nous expliquer quel est votre stratégie
pour une couverture de soins accessibles
à tous dans notre pays et dans les
meilleures conditions
merci marc amourette la parole quand
madame ségolène neuville djaber d'état
chargé des personnes handicapées de la
lutte contre l'exclusion
merci monsieur le président mesdames et
messieurs les députés madame la députée
claude greff
je vous prie d'abord d'excusés la
ministre de la santé marisol touraine
qui est en déplacement avec le président
de la république
madame la députée pour être tout à fait
franche il met tout à fait agréable de
vous entendre ainsi défendre l'hôpital
public parce que je n'oublie pas que
vous aviez supprimer le service public
hospitalier
voyez vous et oui c'est la réalité et je
vais vous dire que comme marisol
touraine l'a annoncé à plusieurs
reprises il n'y a pas et il n'y aura pas
de plan national de fermeture des lits à
l'hôpital public
monsieur poisson je vous invite à le
public je veux vous rappeler ils vont
quand même certains chiffres depuis 2012
que s'est il passé
augmentation de plus de 5% des effectifs
para médicaux à l'hôpital
oui madame bref c'est la réalité c'est
la réalité près de 22000 poste nouveau à
l'hôpital public
les faits parlent d'eux-mêmes et
démontre que le gouvernement entend
préserver les effectifs hospitaliers
il n'y a pas eu et il n'y aura pas de
baisse des effectifs à l'hôpital public
en ce qui concerne les budgets c'est
plus de 1,3 milliard d'euros qui
supplémentaires qui ont été consacrés
aux établissements de santé
depuis que nous sommes en responsabilité
alors la réforme du plan triennal
d'économie de l'assurance maladie nous
l'assumons pleinement
elle vise à préserver l'accès de tous au
service public hospitalier celui que
vous aviez donc supprimés et que nous
avons réintroduit dans la loi de santé à
optimiser l'organisation des soins pour
répondre aux nouveaux besoins comme les
prises en charge ambulatoire et elles ne
visent en aucun cas à réduire l'emploi
des lieux dans les hôpitaux
bien au contraire ce gouvernement
considère à l'inversé de ce qui se
passait précédemment qu'il est essentiel
de s'appuyer sur les forces vives de
l'hôpital public est mieux de les
soutenir de les accompagner dans leur
mission difficile alors que sur vauban
pour tout vous dire vous êtes les
premiers à vouloir leur supprimer des
moyens
merci madame neuville la parole etc